Why do you have a bat?
Please just look at me.
Yeah, I was the goalie.
I love you.
What are you doing here?
Kiss him.
You're in goal.
-I've never played.
-I know.
Scoring some shots will give
the boys a confidence boost.
It's a first-day-back thing.
Get them energised,
fired up.
What about me?
Try not to take any
in the face.
You want to be
co-captains now?
We've, uh, gotten past
our differences.
That doesn't sound
very competitive.
-Who taught you that crap?
-You did.
Because you're
a great coach.
They're right.
I am a great coach.
Nice driving, Kate.
You let this happen,
you stupid old man.
All you saw was him.
This looks expensive.
Yeah, 900 bucks.
And how expensive is this?
He destroyed our family.
Take him.
Your family…
is right in front of you.
We got it, sir.
Found the jeep.
Drop their weapons.
Yes, sir.
Nathan, I always forget.
How many bones
in the human body?
I don't know. Let's count.
That's one.
It's OK.
Lydia never believed
I was one of the good guys
anyways.
She'll believe me.
Jackson.
Is it over?
I'm not getting
anything either.
Does it hurt anymore?
No.
Good.
Mum!
Is this a party or a date?
Maybe both.
And her name is?
Allison.
Nice.
Thank you.
We don't need
to have a talk, do we?
You alright?
Uh, I-- I think so.
Who knocked you out?
One of my friends
or one of yours?
I'm not sure I have
any friends right now.
Not sure I blame them.
You're OK to stand?
We're gonna need your help.
With what?
Taking back the hospital.
Mason, there's gotta
be something going on.
No, you remember
we're freshmen, right?
We just got off
a school bus.
We're not gonna be hitting
the clubs till 4:00 a.m..
OK, movie at your place,
9:00, OK?
You OK?
Yeah.
Except I think that this
bedpan was still being used.
Please don't kill me.
Do you know
who wrote that list?
Laura. Laura Hale.
Do you know
why she was looking for you?
I know why.
Turn around, Adrian.
Turn around
and I'll show you.
-Turn around!
-No, please.
Look at me.
Look at what you've done.
Get down!
Two…
bodies?
No blood, no wounds.
What do they look like?
Statues.
Greek.
Peter, close your eyes.
Do it. Close them now--
What the hell?
What if silver is like
a poison to them?
What if it needs
to stay in the body?
What if that's what she
was trying to tell Scott…
what she was
trying to tell you?
That she'd figured it out.
These four
were still setting
when she went off
to meet Scott.
We can stop them.
Dude, watch the paint job.
Is it over?
Now it's over.
Good to see you, coach.
Stay right there!
Hang on, hang on!
This little delinquent
belongs to me.
Drop your weapons!
Parrish, drop their weapons.
Yes, sir.
I thought you said
you wanted to make friends.
Not like that.
You said you wanted
to be noticed.
I could set myself on fire
and be noticed.
-Well, then you'd be dead.
-Exactly.
Kira.
You don't have to do this.
I made a deal with them.
I need to.
It's not for my parents.
It's not for you.
It's for me.
How long is it gonna take?
As long as it takes.
Keep it for me.
Keep it safe.
What are you doing here?
Huh?
This is private property.
Scott, what happened
to your eyes?
I had to. I'm sorry.
Scott, you have to heal.
If your eyes stay
like this much longer,
the damage
is gonna be permanent.
Mum, three calls
on my first day
is a little overdoing it.
Everything except a pen.
Oh my God, I didn't
actually forget a pen.
OK, OK, I gotta go.
Love you.
I love-- I love you…
Scott…
Scott McCall.
Don't. Please, don't.
Allison, don't, please.
You have to tell my dad.
Tell him…
Tell-- You have to--
No.
Hey, Liam, wanna explain
what that was out there?
What do you mean?
That little display,
your little circus act.
What circus act?
You caught every shot.
I was in goal.
Yeah, but nothing, not
a single shot got past you.
Yeah, I was the goalie.
-Who taught you that crap?
-You did.
Because you're
a great coach.
Malia, you said something
about guilt the other day.
You said it came
with a visceral reaction.
I said it made me feel
sick to my stomach.
Guilt often
becomes physical.
I'm trying.
It's just not working.
-I can't focus.
-Hey, hey. Look at me.
Yes, you can.
Just concentrate.
I can't.
I can't-- I can't do it.
Yes, you can. Scott,
please, just look at me.
Malia…
Kiss him.
What?
That jacket
is absolutely killer.
Where'd you get it?
Kiss him.
You weren't
answering your phone.
Why do you have a bat?
I thought
you were a predator.
A pre--
Come on, Scott, concentrate.
I'm trying.
It's just not working.
Stiles, what the hell
are you doing?
My friends…
my pack.
And you can be with us
if you want…
but you're gonna
have to fight.
Against Monroe?
And everyone
that follows her.
She said she'd find me,
that she'd hunt me down
and kill me.
She didn't care
how old I was.
She said I was a monster.
You're not a monster.
You're a werewolf…
like me.